sie sind ja mutig dass sie hier
unterwegs sind obwohl wir noch senioren
mit dem autofahren wer eine der
gefährlichsten gangs der welt die
liberalen senioren von hannover abgeben
ist für sie keine option
sie sind herr kobusch der chef der
liberalen senioren in der region
hannover ja und sie wehren sich
ich wehre mich dagegen dass manchen
gruppen in der gesellschaft den älteren
autofahrern die führerschein wegnehmen
wollen und sie auch die straßenbahn
verbannen denn die gerade älteren bürger
sollen selbst entscheiden wie lange sie
auto fahren und sie sagen solange sie
nicht regelmäßig für fußgänger und
radfahrer umfahren denke ich können sie
am steuer sitzen tja fahrschein statt
führerschein auch solche ideen können
auch nur junge leute kommen ein
sinnvoller vorschlag oder doch senioren
hat ich persönlich finde dass man sich
ab einem gewissen alter gedanken machen
sollte ob ich noch in der lage bin zu
fahren eine reaktionszeit noch so gut
ist usw
jedoch kann ich nicht über andere
menschen entscheiden und möchte das auch
gar nicht möchte ein angebot machen und
ich möchte auch noch mal das sie nicht
ablehnen können ich glaube sie sich ein
angebot war es einfach lächerlich ist
wie das ist ja im grund genommen beruht
auf der voraussetzung dass man den alten
das fahren nicht mehr zutraut dass eine
diskriminierung ist der
altersdiskriminierung wärst du denn
bereit auch wenn die senioren den
führerschein abgeben dass du dir auch
mal fährst zum einkaufen
dafür gibt's ja taxen also nein es ist
natürlich nicht schön wenn man den
führerschein abgeben muss mein
schwiegervater hat abgeben nachdem japan
über die rote ampel gefahren ist auch
zwei fuß gelegt hat dabei und da haben
die töchter gesagt jetzt ist es soweit
jetzt noch zu viert abheben also beim
ersten haben sie noch ein auge
zugedrückt ausweiten war dann auch mal
gut auf einer skala von 0 bis 10 was
halten sie von verpflichtenden tests du
gar nichts sagen 0,009 soll der fahrer
selber entscheiden unser
verkehrsminister andreas scheuer hält
auch gar nichts von verpflichtenden
tests für senioren ja
und genau ab dem punkt denke ich ist es
zeit ihnen den führerschein zu entziehen
wir ja sie haben gerade andreas scheuer
gelobt jetzt ist es klar dass geben sie
mir wichtig dass wir überhaupt das war
ein guter mann der scheuer der ist
standhaft er steht zu dem was er gemacht
hat und er kommt und ein smarter junger
der große karriere noch vor sich
herr komisch sie müssen zum arzt
[Musik]
haben sie nicht eben noch eine brille
auf ja indem ich es ok
[Musik]
würden sie mir empfehlen jetzt noch
schnell meine mutter zu grüßen ja auf
jeden fall so mama wenn du das siehst
ich wollte nur sagen ich hab dich lieb
schönen gruß auch von mir nicht rosig da
kommen jetzt radfahrer links manche
radfahrer manieren sie müssen abwägen
ich benutze das ist nicht in ordnung wie
müssen hat wir nutzen jetzt noch ganz
wenige ausnahmen und da muss man eben
hogan der autofahrer die pflicht zur
erziehung der anderen verkehrsteilnehmer
mein onkel zum beispiel hat sie mit 88
noch einen neuen bmw firma gekauft und
ist drei jahre gefahren und ist dann ein
jahr später dann verstorben
meine dass vereinen möglicher abschluss
eines lebens und das wünsche ich dann
mehreren auch wünsche dir auch mir das
so dass sie so lange fahren kann
also solange noch neue autos kaufen wie
es geht und neue autos
aber bevor sich herr kobusch einen neuen
schlitten kauft zeige ich ihm einen ort
den er zuvor noch nie gesehen hat
jakobus so könnte ihre zukunft aussehen
ja das ist keine schöne perspektive
nicht finde ich auch und ich habe ja
noch ein führerschein also könnte ich
ihnen auto schüsse haben ja ja dann auch
bleiben sie gesund
ja ich werde mir alle milliarden
[Musik]
so aufnahme
hallo dies ist die automatische and card
von oliver welke und der heute show
leider ist das video schon vorbei ihr
könnt den kanal allerdings gerne
abonnieren und ein weiteres video
anschauen vielen dank so müsse jetzt für
immer reich